j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
volontairement vous le savez décalé de
l'actualité du jour consacrée aux sommes
vertigineuses dépensé par l'Arabie
Saoudite pour se payer les plus grands
joueurs de foot du monde le Portugais
Ronaldo les Français Benzema et Kanté on
cédait au Petro dollars jusqu'où le
prince héritier Mohamed Ben Salman
est-il prêt à aller pour améliorer
l'image de son pays dans le monde avant
dans des bas de Samia de chihua contre
comment Karim Benzema et son Ballon d'Or
sont venus s'installer dans la vitrine
meilleur buteur de l'histoire cinq fois
Ballon d'Or Cristiano Ronaldo et le
trophée de l'Arabie Saoudite le premier
joueur de cet envergure à avoir intégré
un club du royaume à 35 ans qu'il a
rejoint en janvier dernier l'équipe
d'Alsace pour un contrat de 2 ans et
demi une fin de carrière dorée payée 200
millions d'euros par saison
j'avais des offres avec de nombreux
clubs qui ont tenté de me faire signer
en Europe mais aussi au Brésil en
Australie aux États-Unis et même au
Portugal mais j'avais donné ma parole à
ce club pour l'opportunité de développer
non seulement le football mais aussi
l'autre partie de cette incroyable pays
l'autre partie de ce pays comme dit
Christiano Ronaldo c'est l'image
positive que voudrait vendre l'Arabie
Saoudite au monde entier vendre du rêve
sportif pour faire oublier sa réputation
de pays peu respectueux des droits de
l'homme et pour ça la monarchie dispose
de moyens inégalable doté de plus de 600
milliards de dollars un fonds
d'investissement souverain est alimenté
pour recruter des stars du ballon rond
un coup de pétrodollar après Ronaldo
colo Kanté kalidu Coulibaly et plus
récemment Karim Benzema viennent tu
aussi de rejoindre des clubs saoudiens
la Cristiano Ronaldo qui est là-bas ok
un ami donc c'est bien c'est bien de le
retrouver là-bas en Arabie Saoudite et
ça montre aussi que l'Arabie Saoudite
commence à monter de plus en plus au
niveau au niveau mondial c'est superstar
intègre un championnat beaucoup moins
prestig
ieux PN mais
les saisons pour relever
le nid la présence d'un joueur de
l'envergure de Karim Benzema sur les
terrains saoudiens avec Cristiano
Ronaldo avant lui et espérons-le d'autre
star du foot des pays européens et
latino-américains constituera une étape
importante pour le championnat saoudien
si Dieu le veut le championnat saoudien
deviendra l'un des cinq meilleurs au
monde
pas sûr que le recrutement de quelques
têtes d'affiches suffisent à faire
entrer le royaume dans l'élite du
football mondial mais ce n'est peut-être
pas là le premier objectif de Riyad en
pleine opération de diplomatie par le
sport
des milliards de dollars de Petro
dollars pour se racheter une image c'est
le thème de notre débat consacré à
l'Arabie Saoudite et à son prince
héritier Mohamed Ben Salman avec Pascal
Boniface bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
géopolitologue fondateur et directeur de
l'iris et auteur de géopolitique du
sport qui qui est réédité en poche aux
éditions duo Myriam benrad bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
professeur de relation internationales à
l'Université Internationale Schiller à
Paris et auteur de ce livre l'état
islamique est-il d'effet qui vient de
paraître aux éditions du CNRS Fabien
Archambault bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi historien maître de conférence à
l'Université Paris impantéon Sorbonne
spécialiste du sport au 20e siècle et
Mathilde Siro éditoris politique est
resté à mes côtés allez on démarre
Pascal Boniface cette offensive menée
par l'Arabie Saoudite sur les meilleurs
joueurs du du foot mondial est-ce que
c'est sans précédent non c'est il y a
des précédents c'est le New yorkosmos au
début de 70 qui prend Pelé qui prend des
qui sont les stars mondiales et on veut
lancer le football aux États-Unis crée
un football professionnel et donc là il
y a d'autres stars etc ça va pas marcher
mais on a parlé que de ça pendant
quelques années donc le fait d'attirer
avec une somme d'argent plus importante
que non les clubs européens des stars
plutôt en fin de carrière d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas sans précédent il y a un
précédent là disons que on a le
sentiment que c'est plus sur la durée et
que par ailleurs il y a pas uniquement
les stars vieillissantes il y a aussi
des joueurs qui sont dans la force de
l'âge qui sont au milieu de leur
carrière et qui viennent donc c'est pas
seulement briller il y a vraiment la
volonté de créer un championnat
compétitif avec peut-être d'ailleurs le
danger que Hervé Renard l'ancien
sélectionneur de l'Arabie Saoudite
maintenant en section véhicule de France
féminine mettent en avant attention ne
prenez pas trop le joueur parce que
l'équipe nationale risque de bâtir de
l'excès de bons joueurs dans le
championnat mais en tous les cas alors
il y a en fait il copie la Folio cosmos
et il copie aussi un peu le Qatar bien
sûr se faire voir par le sport être
candidat pour la Coupe du monde du monde
acheter un club en Europe eux c'est
Newcastle pour exister sur la carte mais
ils ont la réussite c'est en PIB c'est
cinq fois le Qatar effectivement avec
donc potentiellement une efficacité plus
importante Myriam benrad sépa à nouveau
on l'a dit c'est on peut parler de la
diplomatie sportive du soft power lié à
la diplomatie sportive c'est ce qui est
à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui oui je suis tout
à fait d'accord parce que c'est vrai que
ça nous paraît finalement étrange enfin
c'est il y a une dimension culturaliste
finalement dans dans ce Brouard autour
de ce que font le Qatar l'Arabie
Saoudite les Émirats arabes unis parce
que ce sont des pays qu'on attendait pas
là mais la diplomatie sportive comme la
souligné parce qu'elle Boniface c'est
quelque chose de très très ancien ça
fait partie évidemment oui de cette de
ces stratégies de puissance douce soft
power pour prendre le terme proposé par
Joseph naï qui sont des stratégies
d'attractivité d'image de réputation
mais dans le cas de l'Arabie Saoud c'est
quand même très cohérent parce qu'il
faut quand même rappeler que alors on
peut y voir de l'opportunisme mais il y
a aussi cette vision la fameuse vision
2030 qui a été mise en avant il y a
quelques années par le prince héritier
et qui annonce très clairement que
l'ambition et de transformer le royaume
sur le plan sociétal sur le plan
culturel économique avec je pense des
visées sérieuses alors on peut après il
y a un autre argument dans les débats
sur cette question c'est le l'argument
du sport soithing on fait oublier
finalement évidemment les violations
scandaleux qui se sont produits etc à
travers le sport moi je ne pense pas que
ça qu'on puisse limiter quand même ce
qui se passe actuellement à cela non
mais c'est ce qui différencie la période
américaine on va dire new yorkosmos de
la période de la période actuelle oui
mais les choix
les d'investissement dans certains clubs
comme vous l'avez dit le choix de
certaines personnalités montrent que ce
n'est pas purement des questions d'image
il y a quand même une volonté de se dire
se différencier de et puis un certain
sérieux tout de même je trouve sur
certains enfin en tout cas sur plusieurs
choix qui ont été faits c'est
intéressant famille à Chambeau avec
effectivement là on a évoqué la volonté
peut-être de créer un championnat qui
qui tienne la route c'est à dire alors
bon avec quel public dans les stats ils
y sont mais voilà il y a est-ce qu'il y
a une culture du foot est-ce qu'on aura
la même passion dans ces stades ça moi
j'en doute mais mais avec donc un
élément une différence pour reprendre ce
que Boniface il y a 40 ans 50 ans même
c'était des vieux des joueurs vraiment
finissants on peut dire ça d'un
Cristiano Ronaldo on peut moins dire ça
à Ngolo Kanté ou d'autres joueurs qui
signent en Arabie Saoudite donc ça
perturbe les grands championnats
européens actuellement plus peut-être
que ce qui s'était passé à l'époque
américaine oui encore que je suis pas
vraiment sûr c'est à dire que
Benzema voilà il y avait enfin ils ont
quand même passé la trentaine et leur
plus belle année son dernier e et la
difficulté voilà on verra plutôt par
exemple Bernardo Silva qu'elle est lié
droit de Manchester City si là il arrive
s'ils arrivent à faire venir un joueur
comme ça qui est encore je dis ça parce
que John Textor alors on va essayer de
s'adresser à tous ceux qui connaissent
pas le football le Texas c'est le le
milliardaire américain qui a racheté
l'Olympique Lyonnais et qui possède
beaucoup de clubs au niveau mondial ou
des parts dans plusieurs clubs il a dit
il faut que c'était hier que quand même
lui il est les clubs de d'Arabie
Saoudite donc l'état essayer de lui
piquer des joueurs des entraîneurs
partout dans tous ces clubs oui bah à ce
moment des vieux oui alors ce qui ça
peut s'expliquer pour Textor c'est que
Textor et ne possède pas des clubs qui
sont parmi les plus riches qui sont
championnats les plus riches donc il a
Botafogo à riojaneiro il a l'Olympique
Lyonnais donc c'est des cibles qui sont
faciles en fait pour des investisseurs
qui voudraient rapidement
de débaucher des bons joueurs
alors plus généralement c'est un peu ce
que vous dites sur le championnat
effectivement on peut se dire est-ce que
c'est pas clinquant c'est à dire qu'on
fait venir Cristiano Ronaldo on essaye
de faire venir Lionel Messi voilà pour
épater la galerie en quelque sorte mais
je suis assez d'accord avec ce que vous
disiez c'est que on a l'impression que
c'est une stratégie qui est quand même
une stratégie à long terme donc il y a
eu le Qatar enfin il y a eu la
concurrence du Qatar donc qui avait
frappé fort en organisant la Coupe du
monde donc ce sera pas facile pour
l'Arabie Saoudite d'obtenir
l'organisation d'une coupe du monde on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais il y a
quand même l'idée que
dans l'Asie c'est-à-dire la
Confédération asiatique où il y a une
ligue des champions asiatiques où il y a
un championnat d'Asie de football
effectivement faire venir des bons
joueurs permettent d'élever le niveau
des joueurs locaux alors évidemment
après il y a ce qui s'est passé pour les
autres
grands riches du football avant le
ensuite le la question du dosage et de
l'équilibre apparemment l'Italie ou
pendant quasiment 80 ans c'était les
clubs les plus riches du monde il y
avait des polémiques incessantes sur à
force d'acheter les meilleurs nos jeunes
ne peuvent pas mais là on en est plutôt
quand même une phase l'arbitre et un
pays de football un grand pays de
football comme on le Moyen-Orient et une
grande terre de football et il s'agit
plus que le Qatar plus que bah ils sont
plus nombreux déjà simplement et surtout
en gros l'idée c'est que dans les 20 30
prochaines années l'avenir du monde et
du sport se jouera en Asie dire les
concurrences ce seront les Indiens et
les Chinois et là il faudra les battre
intéressant à falloir qu'on accepte
peut-être leur équipe nationale
pendant la coupe du monde on aurait bien
aimé que qu'il soit pas les seuls mais
en fait la texture bon il est bien
gentil il est pas en des années les
clubs européens ont pillé tous les
continents les meilleurs joueurs
africains les meilleurs joueurs
latino-américains et les meilleurs
joueurs asiatiques venaient dans les
cinq grands championnats européens qui
se libèrent la Champions League et donc
on a leurs pieds ou attiré parce que les
gens on les a pas forcés à venir en
Europe ils ont les européen permettait
d'avoir des salaires que les clubs
latino-américains ou africains ne
pouvaient pas apparaître et là tout d'un
coup on voit qu'il y a une concurrence
effectivement et comme vous le dites il
y a aussi la concurrence une tentative
en Chine et puis qui s'est arrêté assez
vite avec également des vieilles
vedettes payer très très cher des
records le transferts n'a pas insisté
là-dessus bah donc il faut s'habituer à
la concurrence l'Europe va être
concurrencée par d'autres terres du
football avec effectivement ces sommes
qui sont extravagantes le Lionel Messi
donc le stratège souvent présenté comme
le meilleur joueur de l'histoire on lui
proposait une enveloppe alors la les
chiffres sont évidemment difficiles à
vérifier mais autour de d'un milliard de
dollars sur trois ans Myriam benrad
quand on entend ses sommes on se dit
c'est presque indécent mais si on
rapporte ça au pétrole à ce que le les
énergies fossiles rapportent à l'Arabie
Saoudite finalement c'est pas énorme on
peut dire ça
enfin en tout cas c'est pas la
diplomatie sportive qui va alors il y a
cette c'est vrai qu'à la thèse de la
diversification des économies locales
c'est une stratégie qui est pour revenir
sur cette notion de long terme celle du
Qatar par exemple qui est assis sur plus
de deux siècles de ressources gasières
mais qui a choisi à très tôt dans la
foulée aussi de ce que les Émirats
arabes unis en lançaient de de se lancer
dans cette perspective de
diversification de son économie l'Arabie
Saoudite on en est loin c'est pas du
tout le même on n'est pas au même stade
de Boom comme celui qu'on a vu par
exemple à Dubaï ou dans d'autres zones
mais il y a quand même cette idée
excusez-moi de développer une le secteur
du tourisme de de copier un peu les
voisins puissant parce que ça quand même
suscité beaucoup d'admiration je suis
beaucoup chez beaucoup de gens chez
saoudiens eux-mêmes même s'il ne l'avoue
pas on voit très bien qu'il y a ces
rivalités en jeu maintenant ce n'est pas
quand même le revenu important ce sont
des investissements
négatif à l'extérieur comme à
l'intérieur du royaume mais qui en rien
ne sont comparables à ce que la rente
continue évidemment de générer de
rapporter à l'Arabie Saoudite
parce que si on compare ce que coûte
potentiellement ces investissements dans
le football à l'Arabie saoudite à ce que
rapporte le pétrole je sais pas chaque
jour ou chaque mois c'est vraiment quoi
par rapport aux dépenses militaires et
dépense sportifs sont pilotes par
rapport à des pensées ces pays regorgent
de ressources et donc ils veulent à la
fois être visibles et de façon positive
soit carte du monde et puis comme vous
l'avez dit aussi un enjeu de société
interne monaliser le pays donné d'autres
perspectives à la jeunesse passer d'une
économie de rente ou des problèmes
d'obésité dans ces pays parce que
effectivement ils sont habitués à avoir
des rangs etc donc c'est aussi pour même
BS à sa manière assez disons violente
veut secouer la société saoudienne et
donc il y a à la fois l'image
internationale mais aussi changer la
société par le biais du sport et
dépenses qui peuvent paraître évitement
faramineuses lorsque l'on est en Europe
etc en fait par rapport au moyen qu'ils
ont c'est vraiment rien du tout par
rapport à d'autres dépenses ou même
leurs dépenses personnelles qu'ils
peuvent faire lorsqu'ils vont dans un
endroit etc donc voilà les sommes
peuvent choquer mais il faut le comparer
vous allez citer le 600 milliards de ce
fonds d'investissement dans le premier
reportage bah donc le nombre de
followers que Cristiano Ronaldo le
nombre d'attention de publicités
gratuites parce que c'est aussi dire que
l'arbicie c'est une terre de tourisme
c'est pas évident au départ et donc
comme ils veulent d'ici 2030 montrent
que leur économie ne dépend pas que du
pétrole et des visites à la Mecque et
ben des matchs de foot et montrer les
paysages du désert c'est un enjeu
essentiel alors quand on demande à Karim
Benzema pourquoi il a dit oui au club
daltyad qui est basé dans la ville de
Jeddah voilà ce qui répond
déjà pourquoi j'ai choisi
[Musique]
un club avec beaucoup de valeur
c'est un club qui vient de gagner qui
est toujours en progression
et
j'aime l'ambition le caractère des des
femmes donc c'est pourquoi j'ai choisi
ce club là bon il oublie mais voilà on
va le faire à sa place un élément majeur
le contrat et estimé par le média
sportif front office sport à 643
millions de dollars pour trois saisons
est-ce que il renoncent de fait au
football de haut niveau car une Benzema
vous avez un tout petit peu répondu à la
question tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
vous entendre là-dessus ah bah oui oui
complètement mais c'était comme c'était
le cas de peler quand il est allé au
cosmos ou quand il partait en Chine ou
au Japon parce qu'avant la Chine il y a
eu le Japon alors mais Benzema il y
avait déjà dit non à l'équipe de France
mais un joueur comme Golo Kanté qui
était le chouchou des supporters
français à la Coupe du Monde de 2018 il
est plus jeune et il a et on va avoir
peu de chance de le revoir en bleu parce
qu'ici vous n'êtes pas d'accord ouais
très bien bon après il est il était
quand même blessé souvent blessé ouais
il sort de plusieurs saisons qui étaient
qui ont été compliquées pour lui c'est à
dire pour ça que les alors moi ce qui me
surprenait en fait dans ce voilà de
c'est que normalement pendant ces
stratégies de s'affirmer par le sport
ils ont le modèle du Qatar qui a investi
dans le Paris Saint-Germain ou des
Émirats arabes unis avec Manchester City
qui
constitue des bons moyens de voilà de se
faire connaître et de se faire parler
d'eux et alors on sait qu'ils essayent
de le faire ils ont racheté Newcastle
qui était quasi relégable dans le
championnat anglais et qui là c'est
qualifié pour la Ligue des Champions
pour la Ligue des Champions
phares au niveau européen et ils ont eu
des tractations avec les grandes ligues
professionnelles américaines ce serait
le baseball le football américain lequel
NBA on la NBA vient d'autoriser des
fonds
étrangers investir à hauteur de 20% dans
les franchises donc en précisant tout de
suite qu'il n'accepteront jamais qu'une
franchise américaine soit achetée par un
fond souverain étrangers mais c'est ça
la deuxième la deuxième stratégie c'est
d'investir dans les deux grandes
puissances sportives que sont le monde
britannique et le monde nord-américain
allez on essaye de faire un débat pas
trop foot qui s'adresse aussi à ceux qui
sont pas fans mais quand même vous dites
Google c'est les champs lui a pas fermé
la porte il a dit il faut avoir s'il
reste compétitif effectivement il est
blessé depuis longtemps mais Cristiano
Ronaldo tout en étant en Algérie qui a
fêté sa 2 centièmes sélection pour
l'équipe du Portugal alors c'est Ronaldo
donc c'est aussi plus difficile de les
fermer la couche etc mais une goulot de
cantine n'a pas renoncé à qui de France
Matuidi lorsqu'il est parti aux
États-Unis a renoncé à l'équipe de
France là ça reste ouvert il faut avoir
si ce championnat du Sud devient assez
compétitif pour que les internationaux
le demeure alors je voudrais qu'on se
concentre maintenant sur effectivement
vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais la la
société saoudienne on l'a dit il y a
cette question d'image pas seulement
mais à cette question d'image dans la
stratégie dans la diplomatie sportive de
du prince héritier Mohammed ben Salman
un témoignage une réaction celle du
président d'amnistie international qui
voilà rappelle ce qu'est le royaume
saoudien aujourd'hui
MBS un bilan en matière de droits
humains effroyable proprement effroyable
c'est la peine de mort l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est le troisième pays en terme de
d'exécution après la Chine et après
l'Iran c'est également le sort les faits
aux femmes ce sont les sort fait au
dissident des personnes qui
osent mettre un tweet contre le
gouvernement sur les réseaux sociaux
peuvent écoper entre 15 et 45 ans de
prison et puis il y a ces 7 jeunes gens
qui sont aujourd'hui menacés d'exécution
parce qu'il soit disant ils ont eu un
comportement terroriste mais en fait de
comportement et terroriste cette
participer à des manifestations contre
le gouvernement ou de participer à des
funérailles de personnes qui ont été
tuées par les forces de sécurité au
cours de ces manifestations et ces
personnes étaient mineures au moment des
faits
Myriam mènera de comment vous qualifier
le régime saoudien
c'est un régime enfin on parle certains
chercheurs parlent de capitalisme
autoritaire on parlait d'économie de
rente de diversification enfin de cette
mobilisation du soft power dont la
diplomatie sportive fait partie comme
comme moyen de projection de la
puissance mais sur la démocratie
proposée par
par les chercheurs c'est que cette
stratégie aussi de diplomatie sportive
participe d'une perpétuation du régime
de la longévité du régime derrière la
façade encore une fois de réformes donc
il y a cette modernisation cette
ambition de moderniser sur le plan comme
je l'ai dit sociétal culturel un certain
nombre de réforme qui seront passés dans
la violence avec un certain arbitraire
mais de manière éminemment stratégique
puisque l'idée c'est tout de même
derrière encore une fois l'argument de
succession de modernisation de
changement de maintenir finalement un
régime tel qu'il a longtemps fonctionné
donc de rester inscrit dans la tradition
politique qui est celle de l'Arabie
Saoudite mais c'est encore un peu tôt
finalement pour pour juger de l'avenir
mais pour l'instant j'y vois pour ma
part quand même une certaine continuité
donc on peut se demander si tout cela
n'est pas non plus encore une fois
finalement doit être pris sur le terrain
politique avant tout parce que la
société saoudienne comment a évoluer
avec les depuis que Mohamed Ben Salman
qui est très jeune le nombre de jeunes
est très important et donc effectivement
cette volonté alors même c'est un peu un
bulldozer il veut moderniser mais si on
s'oppose à lui on est écrasé donc il va
à la fois elle est autoriser les femmes
à conduire mais en même temps les femmes
qui demandent des droits sont
emprisonnés
Jean-Claude samoutier a rappelé tout ce
que l'on peut reprocher sur la question
des droits de l'homme à la réussite donc
ce qui est encore vrai aujourd'hui
et donc il veut moderniser autoriser les
cinémas autoriser les agir et donc le
football fait partie de l'accès aux
loisirs de ne plus enfermer les gens
uniquement dans la prière etc mais il le
fait effectivement de façon extrêmement
autoritaire et extrêmement brutale il
est les deux à la fois et le problème
c'est qu'il a 38 ans qu'il est le prince
héritier et qu'on risque de l'avoir
longtemps au pouvoir et que on voit bien
que y compris Biden qui avait dit je
ferai le MBS imparia il a mangé son
chapeau il allait à Canossa c'est à dire
à Riyad pour lui demander d'augmenter la
production de pétrole et aimerait lui
dit bah non j'ai plutôt la réduire en
accord avec les Russes donc ce qui
montre quand même que finalement c'est
que maintenant il a avant il était
bloqué par les États-Unis maintenant ici
si c'est une ferme la porte j'ai la
Chine j'ai la Russie etc donc en fait
les pressions extérieures n'ont pas
tellement de prises sur lui et c'est un
peu aussi la conviction il va à la fois
améliorer son image tout en étant
d'extrême brutalité il faudra quand même
qu'il fasse un peu attention à cela la
loi islamique c'est qui qui s'applique
en Arabie Saoudite la Constitution c'est
le Coran c'est encore la réalité
aujourd'hui dans ce pays
parle
de compte ce que en réalité moi j'en
parlais encore récemment avec un
diplomate américain qui a été en poste
en Arabie Saoudite dans les années 70
qui me disait finalement peu de choses
ont changé au niveau encore une fois de
de des données objectives de la manière
dont la population est contrôlée des
comme vous le disiez des sanctions qui
peuvent être parfois très brutales et
aujourd'hui qui culmine on le voit dans
la répression et la peine de mort
concernant les opposants les dissidents
dans le même temps enfin tout ça est
très complexe parce que dans le même
temps donc illusent de cette stratégie
moderniste qui répond aussi à une
demande sociale puisque la population
est très jeune la population est très
jeune il n'était pas en mesure il faut
quand même bien le dire aussi de de
camper sur l'ancienne je dirais la
position de ces prédécesseurs de
l'ancienne garde face à une population
très nombreuse très jeune il fallait
aussi donner des gages de modernité mais
tout cela évidemment
et contredit par par la question des
droits de l'homme par cette cette grande
violence qui est déployée contre la
société mais je tiens à le dire qui
n'est pas nouvelle qui n'est pas
nouvelle ça a toujours été le cas en
Arabie Saoudite donc ce n'est pas non
plus quelque chose alors c'est quelque
chose qui nous choque mais ça relève de
l'habitude pour de nombreux saoudiens
quand bien même ils sont quand même la
stratégie la volonté la stratégie on l'a
dit autour de cette table de de gommer
ou en tout cas de faire en sorte qu'il y
a d'autres images qui se qui s'imposent
dans l'opinion internationale ou
occidental c'est critiques quoi
internationales mais au sein de la
société saoudienne il est très il est
admis que le l'opposition la critique du
gouvernement et quasi impossible mais
encore une fois rien de nouveau ça a
toujours été
la même situation
des compétitions il y a un grand prix de
Formule 1 ils ont créé le circuit de
golf ils ont pris le contrôle du golf
mondial c'est-à-dire que en vraiment un
circuit parallèle et complet où ils ont
mis tellement d'argent que les meilleurs
joueurs du monde sont venus ils ont
écrasé en fait ils ont enfin ce que les
Américains avaient essayé de faire avec
le tennis dans les années 70 avec les
Intervilles mais les tournois du Grand
Chelem avait su résister là les majeurs
du Golfe sont inclinés donc il y a
finalement ils se sont regroupés il va y
avoir un circuit mondial qui sera dominé
enfin qui sera financé essentiellement
par l'Arabie Saoudite et donc il y a le
tourisme c'est que près de la frontière
avec la Jordanie enfin il y a Petra en
Jordanie mais il y a l'équivalent de
Petra du côté de la frontière saoudienne
qui est en train d'être restauré et où
il y aura des millions de touristes qui
vont venir donc là il y aura ce contrat
celles comment est-ce qu'on peut
contrôler
c'est réellement dit il y a des contacts
de manière inévitable on va rester sur
le poids diplomatique de du prince
héritier de Mohamed Ben Salman et avec
vous Mathilde puisqu'on va s'intéresser
maintenant aux liens que la France
particulièrement Emmanuel Macron
il est cultive avec les monarchies du
Golfe dites-nous oui en effet malgré les
critiques qu'on peut proférer par
rapport à ces régimes on voit bien que
le président français lui affiche une
complicité avec plusieurs de ces
homologues dans les pays du Golfe on
peut parler de l'émiratif Mohamed
Benzaïd qui a été reçu à Versailles mais
aussi à Fontainebleau les myrs du Qatar
qui a été invité plusieurs fois l'Elysée
bien sûr et surtout Mohamed Ben salmad
MBS qui était convié pas plus tard qu'il
y a deux semaines encore pour la
troisième rencontre en 18 mois et comme
si ça ne suffisait pas Paris soutient
officiellement la candidature de Riad
pour accueillir la la l'Exposition
universelle et d'ailleurs ce que dit
l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron pour
justifier ce soutien nous soutenons le
royaume car il est en train d'évoluer
dans le bon sens il faut l'aider dans
son élan de modernisation et d'ouverture
sur le monde c'est assez clair des liens
diplomatiques qui horripilent plusieurs
associations de
des Doigts de l'Homme plusieurs ONG bien
sûr on rappelle que le régime saoudien
avait été mise au bon après le meurtre
du journaliste Jamal khachogi qu'il est
accusé évidemment par l'ONU d'avoir
commis des exactions contre contre des
enfants c'est dans le cadre de la guerre
qui est mené au Yémen le Qatar aussi a
été pointé du doigt pour les conditions
de travail de travailleurs migrants
pendant la coupe du monde mais pour
autant on se souvient d'un Emmanuel
Macron qui avait préféré féliciter les
miRs pour la bonne organisation du
Mondial plutôt que que d'aborder les
sujets qui fachent pour le moins
publiquement l'Élysée pourtant fait
souvent savoir que dans ces rendez-vous
bilatéraux il est question des valeurs
universelles de la défense des droits de
l'homme notamment dans les rencontres
avec MBS sans qu'on est forcément de
détails sur ce sujet en réalité tout
porte à croire qu'Emmanuel Macron comme
bien d'autres avant lui applique à la
lettre les principes de la réelle
politique ils cherchent par
l'intermédiaire de ces dirigeants à
accroître son influence notamment
vis-à-vis la Russie et dans le monde
arabo-musulman il cherche aussi à
s'assurer des points d'appui par rapport
à l'Iran par rapport aussi au Liban il
ménage encore une fois des intérêts
occidentaux dans un contexte de montée
des prix du pétrole évidemment des
intérêts aussi économiques du pays par
le biais de juteux contrat dans
l'industrie militaire tricolore donc se
voir reprocher pour lui par les ONG de
chercher à réhabiliter des dirigeants à
la tête de régime discutable pèse peu au
regard de cette liste d'opportunités
pragmatique et même quand on se
revendique comme elle Emmanuel Macron
comme un grand démocrate vous parliez de
Jamal cachoui merci Mathilde rappelle
octobre 2018 ce journaliste saoudien qui
est tué démembré dans les locaux du
consulat saoudien Istanbul en Turquie
quelques je crois 18 mois plus tard les
services de renseignants américains ont
accusé MBS Mohamed Ben Salman d'avoir je
les cite approuver l'opération et Joe
Biden avait décidé de rendre public ces
résultats de l'enquête des services
secrets américain Pascal Boniface on est
quoi un peu moins de cinq ans après la
mort de Jamal cachogi il y a eu une
période où Mohamed Ben Salman a été
blacklisté elle a été courte comment ça
s'est passé oui pendant 10 ans un an et
demi deux ans il a été un fréquentable
donc pas être pris aux photos avec lui
aucun chef d'État ne voulait s'approcher
de lui et même Macron était un peu le
premier à rompre d'ailleurs cela du côté
occidental il a acheté à la baisse il
s'est dit bah les actions de MBS sont
vraiment très basses je vais être le
premier de toute façon tout le monde va
y aller puisque en fait il a résisté
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait MBS après
l'habitude de crédit d'ailleurs moi ça
me choque toujours un peu que on parle
plus de jamaicachoui que des dizaines de
milliers de minutes qui sont morts sous
les bombes il faut aussi en parler du
fait des bombardements saoudiens mais en
tous les cas donc MBS il a fait le dos
rond il a dit je suis mon père n'a pas
des avoué c'est moi qui tient le pays on
est au centre la réussite on ne peut pas
l'ignorer et puis je peux une fois
encore je peux faire jouer la
concurrence donc si les clients me snob
les Russes il y a des très bonnes
relations avec les Russes pour la
fixation du cours du pétrole et la Chine
est désormais maintenant le premier
partenaire commercial de l'Arabie
Saoudite donc le pack du Quincy le pack
mythique ou entre l'Europe d'Allah et
Roosevelt je garantis la sécurité du
régime est une donnes ton pétrole c'est
terminé ça c'est terminé c'est non plus
suffisamment d'influence en Arabie
Saoudite et donc il a fait le Doron
pendant un an et demi et puis après tout
le monde revient et tout ceci oublié
mais c'est pas la première fois vous
savez naren dramaudi était interdit de
séjour aux États-Unis et là il a été
accueilli en grande pompe et c'est le
même donc qu'est-ce qui a changé c'est
l'utilité pour le pays qui le reçoit
donc effectivement maintenant MBS une
fois encore il y a la tête d'un pays qui
est très important sur l'échiquier
mondiale et vu son âge on aura affaire
avec lui pour très longtemps et il a une
vision à long terme que l'on peut
critiquer discuter surtout sur les
méthodes qu'il emploie pour mettre en
oeuvre cette vision à long terme mais il
faut faire avec Myriam c'est
effectivement
si on veut faire évoluer la j'ai c'est
très
européocentré ce que je vais dire mais
si on veut faire évoluer la société
saoudienne faut mieux discuter avec
Mohamed Ben Salman que de le que de le
laisser sur le bord du chemin comment
réagissait en fait je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
mais j'ajouterai aussi que le monde a
changé aujourd'hui on a pour faire écho
à ce dont on a discuté précédemment on a
ce Sud global qui fait ses affaires
entre Amérique latine Asie Russie golf
monde africain sans forcément se
préoccuper de l'Occident donc on est
certainement encore finalement sur des
des vieilles catégories de pensées qui
qui nous font croire qu'on a encore une
influence sur un certain nombre de ces
nations mais qui elles sont dans une
logique d'émancipation d'émancipation et
et c'est la marche j'ai envie de dire la
marche de l'histoire il va falloir s'y
faire donc en effet cette idée
symboliquement d'ostracisation MBS ça
n'a pas duré longtemps mais c'est assez
factice finalement on tenait à réagir
par la défense pour la défense de nos
valeurs de nos principes démocratiques
des droits de l'homme enfin tout ce qui
fait l'identité finalement de l'Occident
mais on voit très bien que les
stratégies opportunistes sont vite
revenus les stratégies de puissance
parce que en tout cas ce qui est
important à mon avis pour MBS
aujourd'hui c'est son positionnement le
positionnement à l'échelle
internationale et on voit qu'il utilise
intelligemment un certain nombre de
leviers d'instruments dont le sport et
d'autres et et qu'il a une vision en
effet ça c'est on ne peut pas lui
enlever malgré le côté impulsif du
personnage l'autoritarisme un certain
nombre de dérives ça c'est aussi
indiscutable mais mais ce pays a une
vision et à mon avis il va falloir en
effet et bien composer non seulement
avec lui mais avec d'autres pays qui
suivront la même à mon avis le même le
même cheminement
Afrique du Sud le le l'anti G7 la
révision des candidate pour intégrer ce
club et donc on va voir si la réussite
sera acceptée fin août lorsqu'il y aura
ce sommet des briques mais ça sera là
aussi que vraiment un changement de
catégories si la réussite rejoint les
briques qui peuvent y avoir intérêt et
il y a des échanges maintenant qui ne se
font plus en dollars mais en ré mineby
entre la Chine l'Arabie Saoudite donc
l'Arabie Saoudite contribue à sa manière
à la dédolarisation de l'économie
internationale alors on va continuer on
va revenir plus à la dimension on va
dire
sportive et football stick puisqu'il y a
effectivement vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement mais cette volonté cette
ambition de l'Arabie Saoudite d'obtenir
l'organisation de la Coupe du monde en
2030 et effectivement ils vont
s'inspirer du Carthage propose à Steve
Jourdain de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau rebonsoir Steve bienvenue
c'est vrai qu'il faut rappeler comment
le voisin le petit voisin
de qatari avait décidé de miser sur le
sport oui ironie de l'histoire il l'a
fait en bonne partie pour s'extraire de
l'influence de son imposant voisin
saoudien on est au début des années 2000
des changements politiques importants
interviennent au Qatar et à Doua on a
encore en tête l'exemple du Koweït qui a
fait disparaître quelques années plus
tôt après une invasion du voisin irakien
l'idée et donc de miser sur le soft
power de faire de la diplomatie sportive
pour trouver des alliés à
l'international regardez ce que déclare
les miRs du Qatar en 2010 il est plus
important d'être reconnu au Comité
international olympique qu'à
l'Organisation des Nations Unies et pour
être reconnu dans ce monde du sport ils
vont mettre les moyens oui il y a
d'abord eu des investissements à
l'intérieur même du pays en 2003 est
créé aspectares qui deviendra un centre
de référence mondiale en matière de
médecine du sport la spirzone est créée
la même année il s'agit d'un gigantesque
complexe sportif situé près de Doha
l'objectif c'est de former des Champions
le Qatar va petit à petit se projeter à
l'international en 2006 il accueille les
Jeux asiatiques à cette occasion et pour
la toute première fois de l'histoire
l'ensemble des 45 pays membres du comité
olympique d'Asie participe à la
compétition en 2007 il devient le
sponsor du Prix de l'Arc de Triomphe
référence internationale en matière de
course hippiques et puis et puis
évidemment boucler final en 2010 il est
désigné par la FIFA comme organisateur
de la Coupe du Monde 2022 mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle a rapporté au Qatar
cette coupe du monde alors on l'a
beaucoup dit mais il faut le rappeler un
les dépenses pour l'organisation du
Mondial ont été
pharaonique 220 milliards de dollars
c'est tout simplement la note la plus
salée de l'histoire à titre de
comparaison la Coupe du monde en Russie
avait coûté 11 milliards et demi oui
parce que le Qatar est grand comme
l'Île-de-France mais la plus grande
partie du territoire est un désert il a
donc fallu construire depuis 0 les
infrastructures et les nouveaux stades
pour accueillir les visiteurs autant
d'investissements qui ne sont a priori
par rentables sur le long terme mais
pour le Qatar l'important est de marquer
les esprits de rayonner à
l'international alors cela a coûté de
l'argent mais aussi les vies humaines
puisque plusieurs milliers de
travailleurs immigrés sont morts en
participant à l'effort de modernisation
du pays c'est le côté face de la pile
Thomas oui il a diplomatie par le sport
permet d'attirer l'attention du monde
entier mais elle contribue aussi à
révéler ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
des régimes les plus autoritaires
notamment les abus commis en matière de
droits de l'homme merci si Jourdain pour
toutes ces explications et ce petit
flash-back ce retour en arrière Fabien
Chambeau
ça va quand même être plus compliqué
pour l'Arabie Saoudite d'obtenir
l'organisation de la Coupe du Monde 2030
parce que on a vu monter toutes les
critiques autour de l'organisation de
grands événements sportifs notamment sur
la dimension droit de l'homme sociétal
on l'a dit mais aussi sur la dimension
environnementale est-ce que vous croyez
que c'est possible alors effectivement
pour le pour la Coupe du monde ça va
être difficile du fait que maintenant en
gros c'est un jeu mondial c'est-à-dire
que l'organisation de la Coupe du Monde
a longtemps
était une affaire entre l'Amérique du
Sud et l'Europe on alternait depuis
l'élection de Joao Havelange donc un
Brésilien qui a été élu avec les voix
des pays du tiers-monde pour justement
contrebalancer la main mise européenne
sur la FIFA donc la FIFA c'est la
Fédération Internationale du fou il y a
eu cette idée de en gros d'ouvrir le
football à des continents qui donc il y
a eu l'Afrique avec l'Afrique du Sud en
2010 il y a eu la Russie en 2018 le
Qatar pour le Moyen-Orient en gros c'est
à dire un moment donné il fallait cette
zone là je pense que c'est trop enfin
pour Ben Salman qui est jeune il va
falloir qu'il attend le longtemps pour
avoir la Coupe du monde de football
parce que il va avoir la Chine il va y
avoir l'Inde enfin ce sera compliqué
pour lui en revanche à mon avis c'est
les Jeux Olympiques qui va viser c'est à
dire que le la même logique est valable
c'est-à-dire la logique de
mondialisation et d'universalisation des
jeux pour le CIO d'autant que le CIO a
de plus en plus de mal à trouver des
candidats pour organiser les Jeux
puisque à chaque fois c'est un gouffre
financier on va encore le voir à Paris
ça ne rapporte pas d'argent ça coûte
même beaucoup au pays qui organise le
comme le Qatar était prêt à en gros à
faire des investissements Farano
pharaonique vous l'avez dit pour
accueillir la Coupe du Monde Riad sera
capable de le faire pour les Jeux
Olympiques et c'est pour ça qu'il
organise les Jeux asiatiques divers
avant la fin de la désire 2029 les Jeux
asiatiques d'été je crois au début de la
décennie 2030 tout ça c'est pour
démontrer sa capacité et faire et donc à
un moment donné se postuler être
candidat aux Jeux olympiques mais quand
même des Jeux asiatiques divers parce
qu'elle Boniface en Arabie Saoudite
je sais c'est une compétition qui est
difficile à organiser mais enfin bon je
veux on peut on peut empiler les
aberrations écologiques en fait ils sont
candidats à tout donc y compris à ça
alors effectivement ça annoncé parce que
ça fait rigoler tout le monde
honnêtement les Jeux asiatiques divers
on a aussi qui n'est pas connu pour ces
montagnes enneigées et la pratique la
luge bon donc ça fait 800 candidat à
tout et des fois il sait pas son envie
ça marche là vous avez pas d'exposition
universelle pourquoi ils auront du mal à
avoir le Mondial vous l'avez dit c'est
que il y a une rotation des continents
le Qatar l'a eu pour les pays arabes etc
donc 2030 c'est un peu tôt
environnementales non pas du tout ça
s'en moque non parce que les pays
maintenant quand même un cahier des
charges de faire un peu plus attention
et puis vous savez les questions
alimentaires on a beaucoup crié le Qatar
on va pouvoir 2026 entre les vols entre
le Mexique le Canada et les États-Unis
il y a aussi une annulation et puis on
les a oubliés assez vite les critiques
quand le la Coupe du Monde a démarré et
surtout que sur l'environnement c'était
pas là le problème principal mais pour
l'exposition universelle et ils ont des
bonnes chances de gagner et même la
France autrefois pour ce type de vote il
y avait des solidités continentales la
France l'Italie est candidate la France
aurait dû voter pour l'Italie mais pas
du tout on va voter pour la réussite et
même pas du tout en cachette on le
klaxonne etc donc on voit bien là il est
venu au forum sur l'investissement enfin
aux formes sur le financement mondial je
pense qu'il a dû prendre pas mal de
contact et il a obtenu pas mal des voix
donc je ne serai pas surpris qu'ils
obtiennent l'Exposition Universelle 2030
et 2030 c'est une date clé pour MBS
puisqu'il a fait un plan 2030 pour
diversifier l'économie saoudienne Coupe
du monde ça va être difficile mais s'il
a l'Expo universelle ça sera la jolie
trophée avec la dimension culturelle
aussi voilà explosion universelle ou
organiser des événements culturels
accueillir des grandes expositions si un
dernier témoignage avec une exposition
Andy Warhol qui se déroule à Lula qui
est cette ville du désert saoudien là
qui voudrait devenir la nouvelle vitrine
touristique vous vous en parliez tout à
l'heure de du royaume on va écouter le
directeur de la programmation artistique
de ce site parler de Warhol
a grandi à une époque de changement
radical dans l'Amérique des années 50 et
à une époque où la culture des jeunes
était totalement nouvelle et dynamique
et il a enregistré et reflété
une période de grand changement de
grande transformation où la culture et
l'art sont au cœur du changement qui se
produit dans ce pays c'est un endroit
très excitant à vivre en ce moment
alors si on dit que l'Arabie Saoudite
s'inspire de ces de ses voisins pour le
sport et le football c'est le Qatar là
c'est peut-être plutôt Abu Dhabi Myriam
parce qu'il y a ces grands musées le
Louvre a été le premier je crois qu'il y
a le British Museum qui va aussi le
Google même enfin il y a une espèce de
Deal culturel à Abu Dhabi enfin c'est
assez impressionnant ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire là-bas
qu'on est en scène ça marche plus ou
moins bien en termes d'attirance de de
Cré tout d'abord et puis surtout aussi
il va il va falloir un moment enfin
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est dans des
stratégies de maturation parce que ce
qu'on a déjà vu du côté cathari et par
exemple Emiratis c'est un c'est que
l'hyperactivisme pour revenir à la
notion de soft power par cette quand je
parle d'hyperactivisme par cette c'est
toutes ces initiatives qui explosent de
part et d'autre dans différents secteurs
ça finit finalement par poser des
questions par interroger ce qui sont
vraiment sérieux sur ce qu'ils font donc
la maturation pourrait signifier
l'investissement dans une stratégie de
diversification mais avec des
investissements je dirais plus sérieux
encore une fois de long terme plus
ciblés pour justement se différencier
par exemple des voisins puisque l'idée
n'est pas non plus de d'être une copie
du Qatar ou des émirats a unis ça c'est
une première chose et l'autre enjeu en
effet
en ouvrant au tourisme si vraiment
MBS est sérieux sur cette question
incontournablement
ça va poser des questions au niveau
sociétal au niveau de comme je l'ai dit
de cette obsession à contrôler le corps
social parce qu'il y aura forcément des
rencontres il y aura forcément les
jeunes vont enfin ils voient déjà ce qui
se passe ailleurs mais là ils vont se
prendre dans le je dirais en plein
visage
la jeunesse occidentale qui vient
s'amuser comme elle le fait déjà Dubaï
ailleurs donc
ça va ça va poser des questions
intéressantes dans les prochaines années
et là encore une fois on est à mon avis
sur les prémices dans 5 10 ans à mon
avis les choses auront encore beaucoup
évolué et lui-même aura évolué parce
qu'il va être au pouvoir longtemps donc
il va devoir aussi transiger composer
merci beaucoup je rappelle le titre de
olive Myriam l'état islamique est-il
d'effet qui vient de paraître aux
éditions du CNRS Pascal Boniface
géopolitique du sport qui est réédité en
poche aux éditions du nom merci encore
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à demain pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public vous pouvez retrouver tous les
programmes de Public Sénat sur notre
plateforme Public Sénat point FR et puis
demain l'invité politique de Dorian
Mancini dans la dans la matinale c'est
François-Xavier Bellamy vice-président
exécutif des républicains et députés
européens vous souhaite une belle soirée
[Musique]